good morning Hank it's Wednesday I must
have either wodsworth constant the
wodsworth constant holds that the first
30 percent of a youtube video is always
skippable most pumpkins are sold by the
pound so pro tip bring a screwdriver and
a straw to the pumpkin farm stick the
screwdriver in there pop in your straw
suck out some pumpkin juice and bam
cheaper pumpkin don't tell me pumpkin
juice doesn't exist muggles if you want
to seem like you've read James Joyce's
Ulysses without actually reading it just
memorize these three quotations history
Stephen said is a nightmare from which I
am trying to awake love loves to love
love and finally arguably the first
eight words of post-modernism Oh James
II let me up out of this
protip insert arguably into ascendance
and it becomes true how do you like them
apples wodsworth how's that for an
entertaining and informative first 30%
writes only two important things have
happened first I have now signed my name
more than 100,000 times in my mission to
sign every copy of the first printing of
The Fault in Our Stars some people think
that I'm cheating or using a stamp or
that the books won't actually be signed
but you're about to see me sign some I
am NOT a cheat - hey hey hey you know
Lorena Segura nerd Factor winner for her
amazing song permafrost well she has an
EP that is out on iTunes through dftba
records by popular demand look how
popular the demand was it includes not
only permafrost but a song in French and
this song fireflies of Montreal
[Music]
night clouds now stars the horizon
flicker from
all straight right travelers who claim
night side lights that has saw the head
in the ribcage sky if placed up or good
as dead
so then what
[Music]
but I've heard from encounters with the
past creatures Shanta Chloe never lies
won't someone tell me after all what
happened to the fireflies a Montreal
darkness in the alleyways at least was
son
[Music]
and the sixties fool away left a few now
there are none but I've heard from
encounters of the past gentle peaches
flowing never last
won't someone tell me after all happened
to fireflies of Montreal
[Music]
someone tell me after all what happened
to the fireflies at Montreal
hey God wanna hurt your feelings or
anything but Lorena is fast replacing
you as my third favorite band iTunes
link in the doobly-doo hit you're still
my favorite video blogger if that makes
you feel better your video on Wednesday
was brilliant I can't wait to see it was
on Monday god
so bad at days alright I'm gonna go back
to signing but I will see you on Friday
I was too much of a dick you Asian that
was like wow maybe I'll just leave that
in